porzingis lost it again and this time  james controls it james all the way to  the LeBron James has put the Lakers in  front come on now this it's the  defensive end I've been hammering it all  night  this guy's played with more energy  effort and intensity on that end that  I've seen in a long time I mean the ball  comes loose yes he's is in a great  position with end to end this is still a  bad man and his get it back into the  arms of Luca James isolating against da  judge a bomb you bet  well brah he's had an answer tonight  gets the switch on to Luca he's East  looks so confident comfortable with that  three ball tonight is he not now 6 of 15  James finishes in the foul  if they went right at it I think they  know Lukas hurting a little bit and so  they they screen with Avery Bradley got  the switch they wanted it oh my goodness  tough cop